hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to episode 34 of game
programming so last time we took a look
at this awesome void tile that we
created and basically now we're actually
able to go on and draw or render these
tiles now we've handled every kind of
exception right we've got the thing
saying that if it's if it's zero right
if if our random generate a level here
generates a zero it's going to generate
a random number from zero to three
inclusive of both if it does actually
generate a zero it's going to place a
tiled or grass at that coordinate which
is great a grass tile rather I'm talking
to encode yeah it'll place a grass
hollaback coordinate which is great if
it's not zero it's obviously not going
to execute this code and it's just going
to give us a black tile right in other
words it's not going to crash the
program everything's going to work
perfectly now we've handled all that so
now we can actually get on to rendering
and the way that we do that is I'm
talking about us pour that into into two
parts as well because first of all we
actually need to handle offsets now I
talked a little about offsets a few
episodes ago I in the screen class here
where I
you know I said that um this XP the the
absolute position is going to be y plus
this this offset type deal and today
we're actually going to talk about how
we apply offsets all right so this is
this is the tile position right but the
thing is if we actually take a look at
this render tile method in the screen
class right now what it tells us is that
the y absolute the absolute position of
the map on the map of the tile right the
absolute position on the map of the tile
that we're rendering is the actual pixel
that is rendering right that gives us a
number from 0 to 15 um yeah okay just um
yeah so it gives us numbers so I'll just
clearing my throat there um it gives us
a number between 0 and 15 all right
depending on which pixels up to
rendering so don't worry about this
first one right that's just that's yeah
but the second one gives us the actual Y
position or you know in this case x
position Y position it goes it gives us
the actual Y position of the x position
of the tile on the map right but think
about it this way what about when the
player actually moves right so think
about it this way when when you actually
move the player the map obviously as a
scroll a map has to move and if you
actually look at these two variables
that we've fretted they don't actually
take an account tape that they don't
actually take into account when the
player moves and that's a bit of a
problem because yeah we need to
basically tell this thing that when the
player moves so for example if I open up
our game here so I can actually
demonstrated if we move this way we need
to be like alright the player has offset
the map I don't know 500 pixels why all
right plus y for example and we actually
need to calculate that so that we can
then update the locations of the tiles
to be in a different location so to do
that we actually need to make a offset a
set offset method so over here in our
screen class just below the render tile
method
we're gonna simply do we're just simply
going to make a method but first were
actually going to make two variables so
up here um right over here we're just
going to type public int X offset and
then Y offset and we're not actually
going to give them any values right now
we could but that's Marilyn a two
because we're going to set them anyway
here but yeah public int X offset and Y
offset
and that's it I should just clean this
up a bit just make it look nicer but
yeah public in X offset and Y offset and
those are going to actually store the
offset value so if I go into here I'm
actually gonna make a method a public
void method called set offset and it's
going to accept two parameters X offset
and Y offset both integers offset and
again what we're simply going to do here
is type this dot X offset equals x
offset and this dot y offset equals y
offset all right so what is this doing
when we actually run this method when
when we call this method we input two
parameters two integers X offset and Y
offset and then what we do is we
actually set these two parameters that
are accessible in this screen class
equal to the two parameters that we
input when we call this method okay so
now in other words we've got these
variables in this class we can now move
on to you know applying them into our
into our render tile method to actually
calculate what the offset is and that's
kind of simple as well
all we have to do here because Ram but
this is the position of the top we don't
want to mess around with this because
that is the pixel that is up to
rendering because so we definitely don't
want to touch the pixels otherwise we'll
end up you know skewing our our sprites
which we don't want to do what we do
want to do though is adjust this
variable right this Y position variable
and the reason why we sort of want to
adjust that is because you know that is
that is the location of the tile on the
map so we want to be like alright if the
players moved 200 pixels to the right we
want to add 200 pixels to this x
position now before I actually do that
but you know all I want to do here is
simply add you know offset the offset to
the X X offset to the x position and the
Y officer to the Y position before I
actually do that help you guys
understand why I want to do what I want
to do now if I open the game you'll see
that if I go right the map is moving
right okay now that's not cool it should
be moving the other way that should be
moving right because remember our player
gonna be right over here when he moves
right or in other words when here you
know walks right um
the map sort of needs to go left if that
makes sense otherwise you know cuz
because in other words what we're sort
of doing here is we're not really moving
the player we're moving the map alright
we're moving his location on the map so
if we hit the right just right now if I
just hit the right arrow key on this
game you'll see that it looks like we're
walking left it looks like we're just
moving the map right that's incorrect
we should reverse it and to do that all
I want to do here is instead of going
ahead and saying that XP is going to
equal X P Plus this X offset I'm just
going to do the opposite and go like X P
is going to mine this equal the X offset
um and again that this line of code is
the same thing as saying this all right
xp- equals x offset is the same as
saying X P equals X P minus X offset
it's just a shorter way of saying it
alright and that is it I'm gonna do the
same thing for Y and that that's it
that's as simple as it is alright all
I'm doing here is I'm saying that we're
adjusting the location the X location of
this of the tile by the offset and same
thing with the Y as well we're
displacing the Y position of the tile by
the offset whatever the offset may be
now that's great we've adjusted this and
now we have an awesome awesome system
for actually figuring out the location
of the map and the location of the
player we've now properly offset all the
tiles brilliant now one thing we do we
do we do need to do is call this method
somewhere because this is the method
method it actually sets our offsets so
if I go back to my level class here over
here are where we're rendering all I'm
going to do here is simply at the very
top here I'm just going to go ahead and
say screen and again we can access
screen there's a parameter here screen
dot set offset and then I'm going to set
the offset to X scroll and Y scroll and
that is it alright all I'm doing here is
I'm setting the offset equal to X crow
and y scroll which of course is the
actual location of the player and that's
it that is how simple it is to actually
set offsets and yeah so I hope you
enjoyed this episode of game programming
if you did please hit like button and
give the video a favorite next time
we'll take a look at actually moving on
to getting the required tiles here and
rendering them onto the screens we'll
see you guys next time good bye